hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jessie and let me know if you can
see the the video and everything all
right if I'm actually moving because
something's wrong with my preview and
it's frozen so I don't know if it's just
me or if it's happening for everybody
so I'm just gonna wait a few seconds
just to get confirmation as to whether
or not my video okay cool
video must be cool I figured it was me
cuz I can't play any YouTube videos
right now on my computer I probably just
need to restart my browser
that's happened before not frequently
but it has happened let's see
so today I've decided to be really
ambitious and I'm gonna try to set up
graph QL to work with WordPress and I've
never done that before
I've never worked with graph QL at all
before so but I know I want to learn how
to do it so we're gonna we're gonna try
it out I've done a little bit of
research about this earlier today but
most of my time has been taken up
working on the catechetical Institute
website that was project one that we did
just minor updates though and some just
some basic things so I figured that
wasn't really worth putting on a stream
alright I got a lot of people in the
live chat so I'm gonna say hi before we
start coding
hey everybody okay cowboy says there
might be audio interference okay let me
know okay Evo actually has a graph QL
API prototype so yeah definitely I'd
love to have that link so send it I mean
you can't really post links in the live
chat but you can direct message me on
Twitter or whatever social media you're
on that you want to message me on that's
cool let's see
alright let's get started a couple of
like a couple of things
Oh for the last two streams I've forgot
to thank some people who have submitted
pool requests this past week so I'm just
gonna do it right now so I don't forget
because I'm pretty sure I will forget
again if I try to put it off so I'm
pretty sure I have those up here yeah
okay cool so I'm not gonna spend a lot
of time going over those you definitely
can check them out yourself and this
isn't a private repo so this is the
Resource Center project too so we have
okay we had to for some reason I thought
we had more pool requests but we have to
let me refresh just to be sure I'm not
missing one all right there we go we
have three that's what I thought okay so
Matt did some fix some warnings we'll
just click into it briefly so obviously
you can read this if you want and check
out what's changed but I had when I had
implemented Google Analytics I had a lot
of repetitive the Annette function for
Google Analytics was just I put it how
to put in every component so the way I
did it was not the best way in terms of
you know trying not to repeat myself a
lot so Matt clean that up which is
awesome so also found a spot where I had
basically had two functions doing the
exact same thing right next to each
other didn't even realize it
so he cleaned that up for me as well and
then Sebastian had to pull requests so
there was some stuff going on with our
forms and just some warnings and things
that got cleaned up and also he noted
some some UI things in Firefox which I
didn't I I did very minimal testing in
Firefox I I can't even remember how much
testing I didn't Firefox it's it's
entirely possible that I just didn't
test it at all so anyway they found some
stuff in Firefox and fix that so really
nice little bit of CSS cleanup and
finally this is some really cool stuff
so on Android added in some information
basically to to let Android know how to
display it how to display the app so I
wonder it's going to be hard to see this
so I'm gonna try it out anyway let me
see the screen so up in actually let me
let me make this but you trying to make
this bigger for a minute
you see if I can there we go
alright so right here we have our icon
for the Resource Center and I'm gonna
throw this into airplane mode so it's an
airplane mode right now I don't know if
you can see the airplane but I'm gonna
click it we get this screen I have the
glares kind of rough on here so I don't
know if you'll be able to see it let me
go to a darker screen maybe to cut the
glare but anyway big lit yeah there's
really bad but this is the resource
center it works like right now I clicked
on the logos page and we're completely
offline which is awesome so I don't know
that anybody here at the University will
ever even try that out because I mean we
have any people at the university that
still want us to like mail them things
like on paper and have no interest in
using the Internet at all or computers
so I don't know how many people who
appreciate that but I definitely
appreciate it also if you go
they're in Chrome the bar at the top now
is the Franciscan green color so anyway
that was just that was really cool I am
I checked that I was showing people I
showed I should the guy that works in
the office next to me and I went home
and showed my wife and because I was I
was super excited about it
so all right so anyway thank you Matt
thanks Sebastian those were awesome pool
requests I appreciate that and now now
we're gonna get started with with some
graph QL so let me go let's see we're
gonna start with this I'm gonna go over
to where we have our code for this
project but we're probably not gonna put
that much yeah we're probably you're not
gonna do that much with with this code
today what we're gonna be doing is you
know trying to set up our WordPress to
work with graph QL
let's let me get my Pomodoro clock going
so I'm gonna do 25 minutes of coding and
then after that I'll take a five-minute
break I'll go over the questions in the
live chat then we'll do another
25-minute session and we'll do at least
two 25-minute sessions after that we'll
see how it's going maybe we do some more
coding or maybe we'll just do a question
and an answer but at least probably get
in about an hour and our code okay all
right so what I'm from what I've looked
up so far and if anybody has experience
with this put it in the live chat I'll
try to keep an eye on the live chat to
see if anybody's putting in some advice
for that but from what I've seen so far
a few other people have worked on this
so we may not have to do this from
scratch it's entirely possible that we
could just pull something from github
that'll get us started so oops I didn't
even start my time all right so I'm
gonna pull over some of the projects on
github that I've been looking at I'll
pull it over under this screen just so
you all can see what I'm thinking about
using
so these are our two really different
approaches and they're not let's see
so this one is act actually actively
maintained this one not so much
but I know that it's probably hard to
see everything the way I have these
windows up but I'll just kind of briefly
describe what what's going on with these
this is more like configuring like an
entire separate server to to run graph
QL and then it's going to pull data
directly from the my sequel database
using I believe they're using sequel
eyes to help with that okay so this one
seems like it's a little bit more
involved this project seems to be more
like a wordpress plugin I haven't had
time to read through all of it but
that's the impression that I got from a
little bit that I did read so it seems
like of the two the one on the left here
this what's it called WP graph QL would
probably be the one that's that's a bit
more simple to work with so I don't know
let's let me give everyone just a minute
or so I want to know what you all think
if any of you have used either of these
before if you have any any advice for me
or if there's something else out there
that I'm not aware of that I should
check out so we'll give it a minute
depending on on what said in the live
chat I may go with something else but
otherwise I think I'll probably try this
one out first because it's more up to
date and it seems seems like it'll be
the quicker of the two so while I'm
waiting for the
delay and the responses I'm just going
to explain briefly why I want to go with
graph QL and WordPress so for this
project in particular we already have a
lot of data in WordPress that I want to
bring in so that's why I'm doing
WordPress I don't want to migrate any of
that data the people that are in charge
of putting that data in are already
trained on how to do it in WordPress so
I don't want to mess up their workflow
having said that we've worked with the
WordPress API in the past and it
definitely works it works well but graph
QL because it will enable us to in one
API call hit all the end points that we
need get all the data that we need and
only the data that we need I think it
would be a lot more efficient to do it
that way so that's why I want to switch
to graph QL the other reason is as I
mentioned you know right away in the
stream I really want to learn how to
work with it on how to use it I've
talked before about all these smaller
projects contributing to the larger
project which is redesigning the main
university website and one of the things
that I do would like to use for that
website is graph QL because I don't want
to have to have a lot of different API
calls happening for every single page so
this is gonna you know work up to that
so do we absolutely need graph queue up
for this project no we don't but if I
don't have it then this project would
basically be pretty much the same as
what we had done for for project one so
I'd hate to just have a repeat of that
we would have a few different things but
I think this would be better you know be
better for me for learning and then you
know better for you all I think just to
have some exposure to graph QL if you
don't already all right so enough time
has gone by that I'm the delay is is
dealt with now so I'm gonna check the
live chat and then we'll be started okay
okay so Arielle says it seems like the
one on the left is mostly PHP and the
one on the right is JavaScript yeah that
was the impression that I got I'm I'm a
little bit nervous about that so this
one is mostly PHP and for this we're
getting yeah JavaScript I'm a little
nervous about that because I'm
definitely better at JavaScript that I
am with with PHP so here's what we'll do
I'm gonna scroll through just the basic
setup options and if a lot of it is
confusing to me then we'll just move on
and maybe go with this because well I
think this one will be faster to set up
if it's all in PHP and things that I
don't understand it probably and it
won't be faster just because of my
inexperience with it all right so let's
let's scroll a bit let's see
was this did you see any setup
instructions there
am I missing something because I didn't
I didn't see anything
what okay that was it
download and install like any WordPress
plug-in off alright well that's that's
super easy okay
well that's worth the try if we just
have to install it like any WordPress
plug-in then I'm I'm fine with that
that's that's easy so I think it's worth
a shot to just install this plug-in and
see what it's like if it doesn't work
for what we're trying to do we can go
with something else but otherwise this
is probably going to save a lot of time
and I'm just going to move this over the
other stream but I want to keep this
ready in case that this other one
doesn't work out
okay so we're
I'm I'm guessing the entire thing then
it's gets installed all right I will
need a zip file for this so let's
download the zip and then let's log in
to log into the same the same WordPress
install that we're using for the content
right now that we worked with yesterday
and that is just my might say we're
gonna use Jessie waggle calm and I'm not
really actively updating this site
anymore or using it for anything so if
this messes it up I'm I'm not really
worried about it that'll just be
incentive for me to actually update it
okay I guess I'll I'll pull this over so
you all can see if you've never updated
let's make it bigger updated a plugin so
there are different ways you can add a
plug-in to WordPress so one of the ways
is through the admin panel here you
could also just access the files
directly and then just drop your file
into the plugins folder so for right now
I think this will be the quickest way to
do it where my plugins we're going to
add a new plug-in and
yeah it's update all right now I don't
want update this right now
in case it messes up no weird all right
so we're gonna upload a plugin so we
needed an zip format so that's why we I
did the zip earlier and where we get
downloads
okay
see how this goes cool let's activate
the plugin and words to that cool so we
have our graph QL API set up I was
looking to see if I have any extra
options here it doesn't look like it so
so I guess there's no configuration
screen or anything okay now let's see
about getting some data just to make
sure it's working
I don't want to have to download a graph
QL desktop thing right now there's got
to be a website I can use
does anybody know of a website I can go
to quickly to test out graph QL
okay let's see
okay
which is gonna be your side day long /
graphic you though okay
okay
and I'm still trying to find a way to
test this
here we go I think I found a browser
client
okay sorry I wasn't checking out the the
live chat I'm gonna test out some of the
the things you all mentioned the la chat
okay
all right so I'm not I'm not getting
anything to work right now I guess I
could just go ahead and do this because
uh oh okay I can just install this with
homebrew so let's do that cuz that's
gonna be easy or the Chrome extension
yeah the Chrome extension might be
easier
all right
set em points
let's see if it works
uh-uh I don't think it did alright so I
don't think we're getting what we're
supposed to be getting
so yeah the endpoint is supposed to be
such graphic oh all right
yeah so we so we have dogs
all right let's check out the ducks and
okay
all right we need to flush the
permalinks would have been nice if they
put that on the on the github repo read
me all right it's the settings
performance those fees paid okay all
right so let's do that
settings permalinks
all right I think if I just flip it flip
the settings that should work all right
let's shut again
yep well it's we had a different error
alright let's see I need
and see
all right so here's what I have now so I
need to put in a query basically which
next step I guess is figure out how to
do a query with graph QL so let's see
I don't want to watch I don't want to
watch a video there's no text that goes
along with it all right
okay so we can we can't add things with
this that's good Lefty's PHP
okay
okay I see Kevin says the fonts pretty
small so I'll I'll make sure a zoom in
on things we're doing it
all right this looks nice real basics
it's what query okay
all right a few more minutes then we'll
do the question/answer let's see I'm not
sure what this data is is looking is
gonna look like
so maybe what was this one again let's
just copy something see what happens I
guess we don't need it
we'll paste that in see what happens
now they
let's check
the post
I need I really need to know what the
with date I'm dealing with
I guess I will need to check this video
today once you graduate you can point it
at your size calculate and planning for
us documentation to started
I'm just gonna watch enough of this to
get I don't know YouTube videos but I
said earlier YouTube videos aren't
playing alright but actually this this
should be enough create those alright
let's just create those all right cool
let's try that
see if this oops see if this works
must have a sub selection all right so
chef selection those edges all right let
me move this over so I can type it out
all right so we're gonna try to get some
posts here
not data date
all right awesome okay so here's what we
put in here basically we're asking for
posts as far as edges a node are
concerned I have no idea what that's
talking about right now it's just in the
demo video that's what they typed in but
then down here I've just specified which
which items I wanted so which pieces of
data about the posts I wanted so we
should just get back these ones so let's
see we did get back all right so within
posts edges
I guess we're we're getting all these
nodes right so we did we just got ID
date title and slug great and then to
compare we had a legacy side by side
what we get from the rest API and then
we get from graph QL so let me find you
find where we had this pretty sure I had
it on this screen yep here it is okay so
let me try to do my best to get these
side-by-side and my my timer ran out so
we're gonna take our five-minute break
as soon as we just seen this side by
side so this is the same data for the
most part between graph QL on the left
and the rest API on the right you can
see by default the rest API gives us
everything right so each one of these
posts has all of this data that was just
one post over here the same post is this
right so by default they're basically
there is no default it's whatever we
whatever we ask for so we've been able
to get exactly what we want based on a
query like this so you can see
a lot less data now but previous project
we have found ways to cut down on this
data but whenever we try to limit our
API calls then we couldn't filter out
our data like we wanted so there wasn't
a good way to both use only one API call
per page and limit the data we're
getting for each API call so that was
our that was the dilemma that we faced
in project 2 and we ended up going with
using one API call even though we were
pulling in more data than we needed to
so with graph QL we shouldn't have to
make that decision we should be able to
do both use one API call and at the same
time get only the data that we need all
right
so let me start my five minutes himer
we're going to do question answers for
five minutes and then we'll go back to
another 25 minutes of coding at this
point it's really I mean we have a graph
QL API up and running so we're going to
move back to our react project and try
to pull that data in and we want to get
that into our Redux store so let me find
the live chats and I'm gonna scroll up
and let's see so I'm getting distracted
there's a lot of messages coming over my
slack at work I don't think any of them
are super important for me I just want a
glance just to make sure okay I'm like
I'm the only person that really has
access and knows about some of our sites
that are kind of important so that's why
I still I glanced at that because if an
emergency happened I I would probably be
the only person that could fix it all so
here's a fun fact I learned on slack orb
right before the stream started that the
person who works in the office right
next to me used to hang out with a
member of the wu-tang clan so he's now
the coolest person I know I don't know
if we have any wu-tang fans in here but
I thought that was kind of cool okay all
right I'm trying to find the questions
there's a it's quite a bit in the live
chat today okay so we had a question
about did you fix the slack link I can't
find in the description all right I'm
glad you brought that up because I
completely forgot about it I remove the
slack length from the description
because basically it didn't work so from
I have no idea where that original link
came from it says that that links
expired and we need to get a new link
but I don't know how to get that link
from slack so if anybody is more
familiar with slack or whoever got that
original link if you're watching right
now let me know how I can get another
link if that's even possible the other
alternative I guess would be manually
sending out invites so I would just I
guess I could say anybody that wants in
slack channel let me know and then I can
just send you an invite based on your
email address so you just have to give
me your email address through whatever
you know channel you want to give that
to me and I can invite you I mean that
method will work for sure but it would
definitely be more convenient for
everyone if if we could get the link
working so so that's where the the slack
link situation is at right now okay also
I didn't start our our serve our end
grukk server I'm gonna do that right now
so since we're gonna be working with
this with the react app now you all can
go in there let me post it post the URL
okay so that's personal live chat now so
if you want to go there we haven't done
anything with it yet but we will be
working with it soon so you want to go
there you can check it out
not much there at this point
okay it looks like some of you were
talking about the progressive web app to
the last project that I demoed at the
beginning on my phone there the Resource
Center yeah so create react app comes
with a serviceworker and and that's
basically what allows it to operate like
that a progressive web app so so you
would want of your app to have some
functionality even offline and then as
you get a better connection it
progressively has more capabilities so
for instance obviously offline you can't
submit the form but if you're offline
you could still read all the content so
you have this core functionality in your
app that always works in your web page
that will work no matter what so that's
the idea of a progressive web app
although I was thinking I'm probably not
gonna do it right now but it's possible
that we could get the form data and save
the form data until we did have an
internet connection and then send it at
that point so I've seen similar things
done before like I said I don't I don't
know that anybody is going to be using
it like that and using it offline so I
don't know that it's it's a good use of
my time here at work but it would be
kind of a cool thing to do on the side
just to get it working so we would we
would need to store that data may be in
local storage I don't know we somehow
we'd store that data and then just try
to detect whenever we got a network
connection and and then send it at that
point
okay Rowland said try Visor you can
mirror your phone on your desktop I
actually do a visor installed I just I
act I hadn't even planned on showing
that so I didn't have it have it ready
but I'll remember next time if I'm
planning on doing something with on my
phone I'll have a better set up Marco
says so create react app automatically
makes the basic progressive web app yeah
pretty much yeah so you so by default
create react app is his progressive web
app depending on how you build it I'm
sure you can make it better or worse at
being a progressive web app but the
Resource Center is actually not bad like
I said the forms obviously don't work it
seems like some of the the images and
everything we're still on there so that
that was pretty cool that that worked
well excuse me
yawning so yeah some of the images
worked I think it just depended on what
actually got loaded before I put it on
airplane mode so I was able to load the
logos but I didn't get some of the
images from the other pages okay all
right so my five minutes is up I don't
know how long it's been up for I just
checked so I'm still not getting the
beeping in my headphones when that's up
so I don't I don't know what the problem
is I probably just need to restart my my
browser it's been quite a while since
I've done that so let me mark down where
I left off at and the latch
okay
all right so another 25-minute session
and then after that we'll we'll see if
we're gonna code more and I forgot that
I had covered this up again so let me
move that up there we go
I had just assumed you all could see the
timer keep forgetting that my my face is
in that corner okay let's move this out
of the way well I guess we have we have
this here so we'll we'll keep this here
now here's what we need to do so we need
some way to bring in this graph QL data
so from what I understand a lot of
people use something called Apollo to
make it easier to work with data let me
know if if Apollo is suitable for this
if you know of something better
otherwise I'm going to try to install
Apollo now and and get that working
okay so harsh it says react Apollo and
relay so do I use relay with Apollo or
is it I could use either relay or Apollo
I have reacts Apollo up on github right
now
hmm
okay so it's either relay or Apollo the
Helio thinks Apollo is the easiest to
start working with okay all right cool
let's start with Apollo is anybody at
experience using Apollo with redux
it should I even be worried about that
or should I use something else
okay so Helio does have experience with
using Apollo and redux okay cool
all right so let's install Apollo let me
find my my terminal where am I there we
go okay so I just had to get up they
jump and what I do it alright so we're
gonna do yarn add Apollo or reactive
part
Apollo sorry should I'd like to I'm
interested in seeing what you all think
do you like it better when we do streams
like this where I'm completely clueless
and we work our way through it together
or do you like it better when I have it
a better idea of what I'm doing and it's
more like me getting everything done and
just kind of narrating what I'm doing it
doesn't have to be either/or we can
always have a mix of the different types
of of streams but if it's like
overwhelming that you all like or don't
like one or the other then I'll keep
that in mind okay cool so we have this
and let's let's see I'll bring this over
here so this is what I'm looking at
right now so it looks like we need to
wrap our root component in this Apollo
okay
all right great let's see pretty direct
component this component works almost
the same as provider community react
reacts affects you that's a store
property new Apollo provider and also
service provider for react redux okay
great so it looks like we can replace
our provider component with Apollo
provider and it should work fine
with with what we have set
with Redux anyway cool so I'm going to
move this over to the other screen and
let's let's hook this up just go into
our app and well first things first
let's import what we need to import is
where we get you if it's import follow
Apolo client
back to Paula and then
if you want to follow along with these
instructions I'm just on the react
Apolo github repository okay alright so
we've made a new Apollo client and now
let's give it some instructions here
network interface
okay so here's what we'll put in the the
route to our graph QL code you know our
demo that we just set up okay so
obviously if you're doing this on your
project you you'd want to put in
whatever whatever yours is or if I mean
if you want to use mine as an example
just to get started I don't I don't know
the care you can do that as well okay
great now let's hook this in to our
provider so our provider is now going to
be our Apollo provider and we need to
add in client that we just made up there
I entered passing the client and then
since we're gonna pass in store as well
based on the documentation it seems like
that that will still work with what
we're trying to do with redux so let me
save that and
all right well first thing let's just
make sure we don't have any errors when
we do have errors polar provider is not
defined did we forget to do this I guess
we probably forgot to import it yep we
did forget to import it
create a network interface is not to
find out it
I hope I forgot to import that too I
don't know what I was thinking it's it's
right there in the in the documentation
I just I just didn't see it
okay cool so obviously we're not seeing
any difference but we're not getting any
air is so now we can move on ahead to
the next step okay all right so let me
bring this back over for just for a
minute so we can at this point pull in
or it's like we can connect graph QL
into our components but I don't think
that's what we want to do I'm thinking
that instead hmm sorry
instead we would want the data to go
into our store and then to go into our
components from the store so I guess
that's that's what we need to figure out
how to do so let me bring up the the
complete reference
I'm just scanning really quickly just to
see if this
okay so here's everything let's see if
they have anything specifically on Redux
integrating with Redux awesome
okay so we've already connected the
store which yep connect the store and
area this is what what we need this is
really small so let me zoom in okay so
so we're gonna keep we're gonna use
connects though
let's see how they how they say to do
this
okay I guess we could try putting some
of this in our in our component now I'm
not a hundred percent sure this is what
I was thinking that we would do but
let's at least give it a shot just to
confirm that we've hooked everything up
properly see if we can get some data to
display so
I wish I could see what the actions were
production graph QL all right this is
not using Apollo let me close this out I
think I want another example so let's go
that's for you
all right
actually they it looks like they were
placing Redux with Apollo that's not
what we want to do
yeah I don't want to do that
mmm this might not be up-to-date
okay this is actually more it looks like
it's it's more like what I want to do
okay I wasn't super helpful but better
idea okay let me check the time all
right
eight minutes let's see if we can get
something to display in eight minutes
all right let me move this off the side
so I can reference it
let's go back here to our home component
and let's bring in I'm gonna do some
copy and pasting just to save time
instead of typing it out bring in graph
QL and
hmm
alright I'm a little bit I'm not
confident that I can get something to
display in probably what is it six
minutes now okay
so let's at least just think this out
maybe personal comments and so we can
start from the same point tomorrow I I
know that were the example that I saw in
the documentation had an important graph
QL here but realistically I was thinking
more along the lines of I guess having
graph QL in here really I'm sorry not in
where am I looking more like in
something like this so that when we
dispatch an action then instead of
making the API call to the REST API it
would grab the data from from the graph
QL API which would then get stored in
the redux store now it seems like that's
not really how Apollo works if that's
the case then I think I need to do some
tutorials on Apollo just to get an idea
of how that works and see and see how we
should be using it if for anybody that
has worked with Apollo if I'm mistaking
if I'm mistaken here please let me know
but I was I was kind of assuming that
basically Apollo would just let me do
the same thing that I'm doing here with
fetch but for graph QL
I guess what I need to do then is look
at query includes
at the very least we can just test it
okay cool so harsh it has linked
something that will hopefully be useful
let's see
shoes
3:48
okay let's bring this over then and this
will be the last thing that we do we
actually got farther than I thought that
we would I thought it was gonna be a lot
harder to get graph QL working with
WordPress but that was that was a nice
surprise that it was that easy okay
okay yeah it's definitely what we're
trying to do
okay yeah that makes sense
it seems like basically one I'm getting
two important things out of this one is
that the data even if I grab the data
when a component loads instead of doing
it like we're we're doing a fetch right
now the data will still be available in
redux under Apollo data in the Redux
store but the second thing is since
we're going to have a search bar I want
to have a live search this is also going
to come into play and that how how would
we do a how would we fire off a an API
call based on a user action so this
probably have to do something like this
as well
okay all right thanks thanks for that
link Harshit that does clear things up
so probably tomorrow we'll be working on
that more okay
all right so I think we'll probably just
be at will be we'll go into the question
and answer now I was thinking about
doing another Pomodoro session but at
this point I think I just I wanted to
read up a little bit more on things I
don't think it would be a great stream
because I'd be doing a lot of reading
and that's not really nice to watch so
if you can stick around and for the
question answer session and help answer
questions that would be awesome
otherwise thank you so much for watching
and I'll be back tomorrow I might stream
a little bit earlier than normal
tomorrow so I'll let you all know on on
Twitter and I'll schedule the streams
you get a notification if you subscribe
to the free code camp channel about what
time on stream let's see let me go I'm
going to go back to the live shot here
and try to answer as many questions as I
can
okay here's some questions here blank
says I'm trying to send data from a form
to Google sheets and I found an article
and medium on how to do that but I don't
know how to set up the last script any
help would be great yeah that's actually
have we have we done that on a stream
those are the first frame you know we
didn't do that yet okay so I've done
that in previous projects but it's
before I started streaming so what are
you are you using react or just regular
Java scripts it doesn't really matter
that much it's pretty much the same
either way in terms of making the call
either with Ajax or with fetch or
whatever you're using so Blake if you
have the code for that on github or if
you can share it somehow share it with
me I'll take a look at it and maybe I
can also send you how I've done it
before maybe that will help
and see
all right not really a lot of questions
a lot of discussions I keep scrolling
trying to find a question
okay let me
would we put that this is it
oh here was
okay there's no schema all right so I
was checking out Evo says if we go to
Docs it should say it should talk about
what feels lower but it seems like
there's there's no nothing available
there so anyway I'll have to keep that
in mind maybe there's something I need
to set up to populate this
Rowen said try so i mentioned earlier i
couldn't play youtube videos on my
browser right now rowan says try
clearing the cache just for youtube I
tried it it did not work so I think I'll
actually need to turn off my browser and
turn it back hunt
it just sounds silly to say that like
that's it's the answers just just
restarted it'll work but it'll probably
work this did happen before and that was
that was the fix
rishabh says can we expect something
about subscriptions in graph QL I don't
know I don't know yet I'm late I said
I'm still I'm very very new in learning
graph QL like as I'm streaming so I
don't know what we can expect with graph
QL but any cool stuff that would be
helpful for this project I'm definitely
open to learning and using on this
project oh cool
John Hansen says I'd wondered how this
would work thanks Jessi for your work
through to get this better than any
how-to video cool
thanks thank you yeah that that's cool
I'm glad you said that because sometimes
I wonder how helpful these videos are
for actually learning things so I
appreciate that
vacation says by the way I'm a fan a fan
not a fan I'm not exactly sure what
you're trying to say but I'll just take
it as you're a fan of the stream and
thank you thanks for watching Kevin says
the four benefits of social media
marketing number three will blow your
mind I don't even remember what that is
now I want to know brush my safe
I'll actually my wafer at this one and
see positive feedback
cool yeah I had big plans for my website
but then I got clients and I didn't have
time and so I just never updated it
again so he only ended up with two blog
posts and I only wrote one of the two
okay so good Nash says I know this is
not a place for asking about something
like this but wanted to know something
about API do you know any way to send
commands from an android app with using
java to raspberry pi using Python
through an API I don't know I mean
certainly I don't think is this is the
wrong place to ask those questions
because we get a lot of different people
with different skill sets that are in
the live chat so I think any you know
any questions fair game because someone
might be watching that that is work with
that I personally have never worked with
with that type of thing
so I'm not sure yeah I mean this is
definitely avoiding the question and I
don't think this will work in your
situation but if it was me and I was
doing it I would just build the Android
app and react native and then I would
use JavaScript for the Raspberry Pi we
use node and then that way I would know
what I was doing a little bit more
because he would all be JavaScript but
yeah I really don't know so I'm sorry
about that
so I couldn't help you but but don't
feel bad about asking questions like
that you know feel free to ask anything
see vacation says can't we use rails you
can certainly use rails I'm not going to
use rails for this project I probably
won't be using rails for any of the
projects that I'm doing for work but I'm
sure a lot of what I'm doing could be
integrated with something that that
you're making with rails
oh cool so REO says guys I found
something amazing word expressed aiyo
this project aims to replace PHP with
JavaScript and WordPress development by
using nodejs and Express to consume data
from a wordpress database using graph QL
it uses Apollo to fetch the data that's
really cool I mean that's just a little
what we were trying to do that sounds
that sounds awesome
it fetched all des fêtes the data and
deliver it into react components cool
okay so I had asked earlier whether or
not you all preferred the type of stream
like either like we had today where I go
into the stream just really clueless
about how to do a thing and then we just
work through it and learn together and
try to see what we can do or the type of
stream where I pretty much know what I'm
doing I've already done it before and so
I just kind of go through and explain
what I'm doing but there's not as much
guesswork and learning as we go and it
looks like some of you definitely like
to see me work through things and in
troubleshoot and debug so that's awesome
it seems like look it seems like harsh
just said harsh it said when I do have
an idea that I know I get through it get
more done yeah that's true so I think
probably what I'll end up doing is still
having having a mix Kevin says I like
both
let's see Zubair says this is super fine
your streams are better your mistakes
make us perfect cool that was that was
the whole point right if I make the
mistake and you see me do it then you
won't have to make the mistake and learn
from it because you've already seen me
do it uh-huh so all right cool so it
seems like you all would like to mix so
I'll try to keep in mind and have a mix
I made it a lot of what I do on the
stream just depends on what I have to do
for work anyway so I only have just a
certain like range of options to choose
from each day to do a stream line but
I'll try to keep a nice mix and and do
both so we'll be kind of adventurous
sometimes in the streams and try new
things like today and then other times
there's gonna I mean you all know when
you're building something there's some
times when you just have to do a thing
that you've done a hundred times before
but it has to be done so we'll still
have some things like that for every
stream you know like setting up for
every project I mean setting up the
server right you gotta set up a server
for every
so that's that's you know not really a
big thing setting up your dev
environment just like basic CSS layout
you know we'll do that as well
Harshit says enjoying the live reloading
and and rock cool I'm glad I'm glad you
enjoy it didn't really do that much with
it but it'll be really cool once we
start putting in UI elements and being
able to instantly see that feedback and
inspect it and dev tools see what's
happening with the store I think it
would be really really cool and just I
know I said this before but it was a
long time ago I definitely want to give
a shout out to the people at n Grove
I can't remember the guys name but the
guy who I guess made and rock he's he's
letting us use it
unlimited for free so normally to be
able to have this many users on and rock
at once it would it would cost money but
we're able to do it for free so he's
doing that for free code camp for these
streams so I really appreciate that
vacation s what are you making
Harshit did say a bulletin for the
university yes so basically it's just
gonna pull in posts from WordPress and
then display those posts and it's gonna
have like infinite scroll for the posts
and you can you'll be able to sort the
post by date caddy a filter by category
so you'll be able to submit your own
posts now they won't automatically be
there they'll go to somebody to review
first before they get put in to the
bulletin so that's I mean that's pretty
much it just display images YouTube
embeds and text and then allow users to
submit a form so it's not gonna be
really complicated now I will tell you
this if we have time I would love to
maybe add in some extra features so
users have to sign in so we you know
they'll have an account right so based
on that account we could save user
preferences so we could say preferences
for how they like the UI to look
we have several different options for
the UI so we could save their
preferences we could save preferences
for I don't know what categories they
want to see at the top of the page maybe
give them the ability to star certain
announcements or bookmark them so that
they can see things it would be may be
cool to have desktop notifications when
new things are available so there's a
lot of extra stuff that I've thought
about doing and I haven't done yet so
this could be a lot more complex it just
kind of depends on what other projects I
have going on and how you know what the
deadlines are like you know if there's
anything really high priority I'll have
to do that instead so I can't guarantee
that we'll do stuff like that but I
would really like to do some stuff like
that if possible
see
Brett says I learned graph QL while
giving my daughter a bath and getting
her fed amazing it is pretty amazing
cool
actually I forgot today is my dog my
youngest daughter's birthday she turned
one today so I'm really excited about
that she's my youngest and she's so cute
and she's also my last because my wife
can't have kids anymore so I just
spoiler because it's my last little baby
so I can't believe she's already one but
yeah actually I want to make sure I get
out of here somewhat soon so that I can
go home and hang out with her
maxime a says who used graph QL and
meteor has anybody use graph QL a meteor
I'm actually I'm really interested in
meteor I've seen some cool demos of
things people have done with it and I
know it's been around for a while is it
still relevant is it worth it to learn
it or is there something newer that
people are moving to if it's still
relevant then I definitely interested in
learning how to use it and doing a
project with it okay cool so Harshit
says I can I can get rid of the actions
that I'm using now in this app so like
right now we're dispatching actions to
get our data I can get rid of that and
instead use graph QL queries to
basically accomplish the same thing
that's cool that should simplify our
code quite a bit Bret said so would we
eliminate Redux actually that's a good
question should we eliminate Redux or do
we still want to use them together I
mean I definitely still would love to
have data in the store to be available
but yeah I don't know if anybody has any
opinions on that please let me know
see
John Henson says while I'd love to ask a
question about adding event listeners
when components are there and then not
then there again think I've got it but
whoa oh yeah cool let let me know how
that goes and if you need help with that
I get yes so if you're using it in
reacts with event listeners I mean
normally when I have like things that I
would normally use jQuery for within
event listeners with when I'm doing it
with react I just make sure the state
changes when an action happens and then
the components will you know we rendered
everything will be taken care of so you
know you like you could just put like an
on-click attribute onto the component or
the button or you know whatever has to
happen or I don't know what they I don't
remember what they all or but for a lot
of the events that you would normally
use like that you would want to do
usually you can just add it as an
attribute and then change the state
based on when that happened
okay Harshit says is Redux compulsory
for this project actually no not really
well to be honest with you I didn't
expect to use graph QL until today I
decided today we're gonna use it so at
first I thought we were just going to do
Redux with the WordPress REST API which
is what we were doing yesterday so I
like I'm open to reevaluating whether or
not we should even use Redux on this
project now that we're using graph QL so
maybe I'll have to do some research on
that and think about that maybe we don't
need it I mean there's definitely some
other pieces of data parts of the state
that we won't make API calls to get but
it would still be nice if it was
available in the store so we'll see
we'll see how that goes
but if we don't need to keep it we can
simplify things then I guess you know
maybe it's not
there's no not really good reason to use
Redux
okay so Blake I just saw your your link
so I'm putting that in my address bar on
my other screen right now
okay so off to take a look at that maybe
after the stream maybe tomorrow because
I do want to leave shortly after the
stream ends so but I'll leave that up on
my screen so I don't forget coder Jim
says I learned a lot for your videos the
problem is only that I don't have enough
time to keep up to date with you yeah
yeah I sometimes I wonder about that too
like I just put out a lot of content
since we're streaming I mean we do at
least an hour every day usually closer
to two hours you know five days a week
not always five days a week but that's
that's what I shoot for I know that's a
lot so I don't know it just takes a lot
of my idea is that maybe I would
categorize the content better have
better descriptions and you know like
timestamps of when I go over certain
topics to help you all to be able to
sift through the material and skip what
you don't need it's just there's so much
of it I just don't have time to do all
that yet but I mean I definitely
understand it's a lot to work through so
for those of you who are doing it and
keeping up with it that's awesome um but
but anyway thanks for watching you know
even if you can't watch everything I
appreciate even you know whatever you
all can watch that's I mean that's
awesome
I should says going to sleep now it's
1:00 a.m. all right good night thanks
for watching okay thanks everyone for
saying happy birthday oh my daughter's
name is Cordelia so we named her
Cordelia Elizabeth and in yes she's one
today
okay cool so yeah so Blake says every I
see
all right cool Blake I will check that
out like I said either today or tomorrow
and figure out how to get that google
that link to the Google sheet working
okay Brett says react definitely
overshadowed media okay all right
Harshit says we'll make a pool with auth
system you need regular email and
password as the method actually maybe
did I miss something
okay so maybe I missed it seems like all
harsh it's probably asleep right now so
if you're still awake and you're
watching you can hear this
I guess that's cool with the pool
request I'm not exactly sure what what
is what you mean about the regular email
and password so anyway send me a message
on Twitter or something let me know
oh okay in my plant yeah so for the
login right now it's a it's a password
this login system so a user goes to the
bulletin and they're prompted to put
their email in and it has to be a email
that ends with at Franciscan edu if it
is that kind of email then the system
right now it's using auth0 which handles
you know keeping track all the users and
everything but they get out their email
a link they click the link it logs them
in and it stores their login credentials
in local storage and they stay logged in
on that browser for about a year unless
they clear their local storage so that's
the current system so if we go with a
you know a new system I still would like
to keep it so that users with the
Franciscan email address could still do
the password this login thing I think
that's best
that way users don't have to worry about
passwords I don't have to worry about
passwords then at some point down the
road I would love to tie it into our
single sign-on system here at the
University which isn't they haven't
launched it yet so that's why I'm not
trying to tie it in right away because I
it's not ready but I'll need some some
information some more information about
how to tie that in I'm not even sure how
they're they're implementing it it's a
totally different Department is handling
it
so so we'll see how that goes
but that's basically what I would like
is as a password list system sending
email links
all right so I've gotten to the bottom
of the live chat hopefully I didn't miss
anyone's questions I will be back
tomorrow
like I said tomorrow maybe around like
1:30 1 or 1:30 p.m. Eastern Time
it's a little bit earlier than normal
but thank you all for watching and for
helping me get through kind of a
challenging stream because it was all
new you know new techniques new
technologies that I haven't used before
so anyway thanks again for watching and
for contributing in the live chat I will
be back someone else on my Twitter was
it's in the description for the video
it's it's at Jesse or Weibull but you
know it's in the description too she's
wanted to link ok so anyway yeah thanks
and I'll be back tomorrow and until then
have a great day